rupert let's touch on you said
earlier epigenetics i think this is very
important i think it's also
very important to see where we can go
beyond
epigenetics with morphic resonance so
in terms of science and understanding
epigenetics this was a
profound advancement actually rosalind
franklin
um francis crick james watson i think
that
um since 1951-2-3
i think that since then it's only been
about 70 years
and we've had now a profound
um transition into
what is now going to be the
biotechnology age
um in this next decade and beyond
where we'll have things like a constant
stream of our bodies biometrics and
we'll be able to make tweaks like
like jets that have hundreds of sensors
on them and we'll be able to also
increase our longevity and retain
youthful homeostatic capacity
and that's all to the thanks of
understanding this code of life
and also to how to augment it and uh so
this is very profound
and and i i wanna explain briefly
that the idea of epigenetics that these
newly acquired behaviors
leave things like dna methylation and
affect histone tails and that's passed
down to
future generations and that's not just
behaviors but that's also things like
the traumatic instances as well and if
you do things like
heal what has been a trauma in your
lineage
it you can actually butterfly affect
that downward and outward
uh and i think that's that's very
profoundly important
cells also have very
interesting processes like this with
their cell cycles and their checkpoints
and where they also have if they have a
certain amount of
protein that's built up that it may be
indicating that it was harder to
have mitosis happen so there is a memory
mechanism
even at the cellular level and you were
mentioning this earlier as well that
a lot of what the the
was a very profound enrichment that
happened from carl jung's work with the
collective
unconscious and archetypes and
dating back to what we were talking
about with plato and aristotle
and their mentality around this
this is this is extr this has been now
triangulated on from
so many different angles
in terms of what is truly underlying
in a maybe a sort of implicat as like a
david bowm would say or
some sort of a source code or or an
or an animistic essence
of sorts and and what what is that
rupert that is beyond epigenetics
well epigenetics as is currently
understood epigenetic inheritance
is um the way in which genes can be
switched on or switched off by
methylation or changes in histones
or whatever um it's conceived of
in uh molecular terms that's
one reason it's the taboo against the
inheritance of acquired characters
was lifted around the year 2000 in the
20th century it was one of the most
taboo topics in biology you could
lose your job and you suffer serious
career damage if you said you believed
in the inheritance of quiet characters
no it's okay um it's a major shift
um so um that's a great a welcome
change uh but it things can go further
you see
now let's take an example um
if you train rats to learn a new trick
um this is one of the experiments for
morphic resonance
yes um it's this experiment's actually
been done it was started at harvard
decades ago you train them to learn a
new trick
it turns out that their children learn
it quicker and their children even
quicker
and it went on over 30 generations them
getting quicker and quicker
um and this was interpreted as the
inheritance of acquired characters
because it was
from the parents to the children and
this became
um very controversial research because
of the taboo against inheritance of
acquired characters
then someone did a control experiment
they
tested rats that had whose parents had
never been
trained in this trick and they found
they were getting better too
they were all getting better so it
wasn't
just something passed on through the
genes or modification of the genes
there was something else going on and
that's i think where morphic resonance
comes in
so i think in inheritance we've got
several different
aspects to inheritance we've got dna
which explains the structure of proteins
and some of it's concerned with
switching on and off other genes
we've got epigenetic inheritance that
can silence or
activate genes and that can be passed on
in some cases we've also got morphic
resonance
and then of course we've got cultural
inheritance and that too
can involve morphic resonance when a
baby learns a new language a language
for example
i think that it's not just a stimulus
response psychological process i think
that that
learning is accelerated by morphic
resonance
so um it underlies cultural inheritance
as well
now would it be fair then to say that
it is potentially both like you just
indicated there is
a a tremendous amount of the
the current scientific paradigm that
is that like you just described
unlocked the the next level of
understanding
genetics and epigenetics and so we have
this
general understanding now and the way
that
that process is part of this this
uh the the in
the inheritance of of memory and then
we have something else that that is at
play
which you've cited the example with
learning with rats but there's also
many other you you give you give so many
other
examples um with with dogs knowing when
their owners come home
with um with nursing mothers and
that their their them being able to feel
when they have their uh the
the breast milk and their babies and
the need to feed you you there's
there's many of these sorts of examples
this kind of is also a little bit
leading us into um the the science
and dogma section a little bit but i i
want to i wanted to just ask especially
on i want to know if there's
both if both these both coexist you kind
of gave the indication that you have
on on a on a body level you have
the genetics and epigenetics and the
further understandings of science
and then there's also some sort of uh an
implicat
or an ethereal or a spirit or soul or
animistic
source code-esque contribution and those
two things can co-exist